special news segments special special
special special good evening I'm poppy
Harlow here for your special news
segment any youtuber mentioned in this
video it's just for context I am NOT
dragging these people it's just for
context full disclaimer guys just
context no for real it it is just
context I think if this story goes
mainstream we should very likely will it
will have a negative impact on youtubers
what am I talking about
well of course better health you've
already heard about it from your
favorite youtuber better help better
help their view better help better I'll
better help the better help that better
hope better help better help better help
better help better help better help
better help there is a list of over a
hundred youtubers who have promoted this
website it's been all over rented my own
subreddit I always see these ions try
online therapy try online therapy and
you too can grow a magnificent beard
just like this guy well what is better
health well it's been marketed as cheap
affordable and private online therapy
with a professional that's right her a
professional i disgust better helped in
a previous video when i first heard
about it and i was cautious about
calling it a scam because i've seen not
just youtubers but actual therapists
chilling this service really really
really good you're a sociopath by the
way this video sponsored by online
therapy so what's wrong with better
health then you can have online therapy
without leaving your house you're gonna
have Thera for you at home that's great
that sounds almost too good to be true
well yes yes because that is with better
help they have attempted to mass-produce
therapy they pride on having 4 million
users and they've gathered this many
users by saying this if you sign up a
better help
you'll pay only 65 dollars whereas if
you go to an actual therapist and meet
face-to-face you'll be paying
250 dollars so look how much money you
are saving by using better help instead
of face-to-face therapy however in their
own terms of service they acknowledge
that if you are using this site it is
not a complete substitute for
face-to-face examination and for a
session by a licensed qualified
professional
so it's marketed as a cheaper substitute
for therapy when in reality it's a
luxury it's an addition to therapy look
how much money you are saving by not
going to therapy also by the way you
need to go to therapy when you subscribe
to better health let's say you pick the
most popular one $65 per week but you
are billed monthly so when the 7 day
trial runs out you immediately build two
hundred and sixty dollars so let's say
you sign up for better health but for a
7-day free trial as soon as that trial
ends you are charged immediately with
the full price of a month two hundred
and sixty dollars and even if you
immediately cancel you are still charged
the full amount for a month that you
will not use and there's a lot of
reviews that reinforce this better help
says how long will I use his service
just as long as you need it you can
cancel the subscription of the service
at any time will discharge you for the
full month anyway now I've seen comments
saying that if you contact them they
will pay you back so if you lost money
signing up for this please do reach out
better help also says that we'll find
you an online therapist will that you
just do this quick questionnaire and
we'll find the right person for you but
in their Terms of Service
they also say we cannot assess whether
the use of the counsellor is right and
suitable for your needs so what do they
do they don't take accountability for
anything you can find a therapist that
does phone calls or texting by yourself
better health says themselves that they
give no warranty for their willingness
to give advice
they'd make no warranty whether what
they say is even relevant useful correct
relevant again satisfactory or suitable
to your needs so they don't take
responsibility for anything
how convenient on review sites it says
that better help is 69 percent positive
and 21 percent negative so if someone
says
better help really work for me that's
because they had a good therapist
not because better help provide a good
service because they don't take
accountability for any of their
counselors which then leads to a lot of
people having bad experiences they say
themselves that they don't diagnose the
platform is not intended for diagnosis
but then you have really questionable
videos of youtubers saying I suffer with
binge eating which I do want to talk to
you guys about because I was officially
diagnosed with binge eating disorder by
my therapist I was officially diagnosed
by their therapist okay who diagnosed
you if you guys have ever heard of Tom
oh really
you were officially diagnosed by a
therapist therapist should not diagnose
you by the way and better help
themselves say that but still apparently
it happens I never actually received any
therapy we just kept studying
appointments and he just kept missing
them and not giving me any warning or
any real reason and was really
unprofessional and his messages so I'm
seeing better help everywhere and I'm
getting flashbacks obviously if you meet
a therapist face-to-face you can still
have bad experiences but if better help
themselves doesn't take any
accountability of finding you the right
therapist or any accountability for the
actions of their therapist then what's
the point what do they do
besides charging you it just came to my
attention that I miss a portion of the
Terms of Service this one is deeply
concerning and guess why I missed it
they deleted it just a few days ago how
convenient this one says that they don't
guarantee the verification of the skills
degrees qualifications certification
credentials competence or background of
any counselor with better help you'll be
talking to professionals just beware
that it's your responsibility to
determine whether they are or not it's
your responsibility to determine whether
they have any degree or qualification or
certification or all these things
better help do besides selling you a
product that doesn't exist that they
don't sell a lot of reviews have spoken
about this saying that their counselors
wasn't really questionable with all
kinds of crazy stories and considering
how little the actual therapists using
better help gets paid it's obvious that
you're not gonna get the best service
people even saying that they most likely
just talk to another person their
therapist just changed throughout the
year and they they don't even know who
they were talking to anymore now I can't
vouch that these reviews are legit
obviously there are not in this reviews
but I can if you want to do that
argument
neither of the good reviews are legit
either if you go to better helps own
websites their testimonies they are
filled with testimonies most of them
starting off with text saying Joel was
excellent referring to their therapist
alex has been so helpful
she is very understanding referring to
their therapist
Jerry is empathetic while you scroll
down and you find this guy Julian says
that better help calm is a reliable
online platform to receive therapy it
can be easier and safer to communicate
with a licensed psychologist from home
than at an office a therapist of theirs
Loren McCoy is attentive and does ask
the right questions you needn't stay
alone Jesus you needn't stay alone and
notice how he says Julian Sands Julian
says the better hope doc who's Julian
his therapist is Loren is he Julian is
he referring to himself
is he reading the script so badly what
is this sign what is going on here the
cherry on the top here is that in their
Terms of Service they can share your
data and anything talking about mental
health related that's that's really not
a problem if that's public information
right I mean the whole idea of having
online therapy with an online footprint
is this a bad idea general why is my
accent so wrong now
this is some of the reason that I found
out that better help is not what they
are saying it is there's a lot of more
information and a lot of more crazy
things that I I don't want to bring up
but there is a lot of suspicious
activity to say the least
for me where this whole thing gets the
most messed up it's the marketing when I
first heard about better help I was
immediately skeptical because I've been
approached by a similar app a year ago
and it very few selected people told me
Felix this app is not what they are
saying it is
luckily the app didn't cost any money
and luckily I didn't take the money for
the promo for some reason I recognized
that it was a bad idea taking money for
a mental health issue and how so many
youtubers failed to recognize this it's
just beyond me well maybe shouldn't be
there's over a hundred youtubers who
have promoted better health but the most
concerning thing about this is not that
they're getting paid to promote it I
think that's fine but they are paid per
person that signs up to better health
and not just a little money either it's
been confirmed that youtubers have been
paid $200 per person that they get to
sign up for better help $200 that's a
lot of money just get a thousand people
signing up you just made two hundred
thousand dollars so obviously you're
highly incentivized to tell people to
sign up for this service in my video
when I mean better help I was just
joking by the way guys everyone is a
sociopath
enter the code Shane for your cheaper
online therapy today I would never have
guessed it well actually this was the
case so this leads to a lot of the
sponsored videos of these hundred one
hundred of youtubers being about mental
health which could actually be a good
thing but they are made so that people
sign up for the website
I'm Scott it's Scott for depression to
expression if you're looking for
anything to miss out on don't miss out
on this welcome to Express whoa I
actually messed up there and completely
serious before we start I have so much
respect for each and every one of you
for watching and being why do you ask
for my payment information now okay as
we know I've been in therapy I've been
just dealing with a lot of stuff that I
need to deal with and I feel good
anyways I feel good that's what is that
probably about
so you can access professional
affordable and kamee and counseling I
just hit a wall where it was was gotten
so bad that it was basically either stop
making videos or disappear also this
video is sponsored by better help more
information about that at the end of
this video I believe having a healthy
mind to be a top priority at least for
myself a healthy mind leads to a healthy
life but before you guys go I just want
to share with you better health it may
seem like you are unable to gain a
clearer perspective you no longer need
to feel the suffering counselors had
better help are on your side probably
bullying 70 80 90 hour work week switch
battle in between of course she got them
in light of this video I'm working with
better help to help provide another
resource for you guys to be fair I don't
think these youtubers know what they're
promoting and on the paper it sounds
like a great thing if you can help
people and get paid at the same time
what's the what's wrong with that I
don't think everyone is completely
innocent but I don't think there's any
point in faulting anyone too much either
recently there's been a big topic on
YouTube about mental health ten
youtubers fighting mental health stigma
YouTube is failing its creators and why
youtubers are feeling burned out I
talked about this topic because I don't
want people chasing phantom dragons I
don't want people to think that they win
by acquiring wealth and fame this is
such a common misconception that somehow
if you get rich and famous all your
problems are shown when in reality these
are just cravings that everyone has that
will never leave you satisfied you will
never feel happy and content if a
service like better health existed they
should take accountability for their
counselors actions it should be in their
best interest to make sure that anyone
that signs up gets a good service but in
their Terms of Service they say that
they don't and this is obviously because
their mass producing it and they
definitely should not market themselves
as a substitute for therapy and and then
at the same time say that they aren't
one and hidden in their Terms of Service
and youtubers should not take a deal
that gives them money per sign up
if it's for mental health or at the very
least then disclaim that I was slammed
by mainstream media a few months ago for
guess the controversy gay guess the big
thing that I did well I shared Amazon
referral links in my descriptions with
ash I've never even mentioned that's
right everybody I linked to my equipment
and I got in 10% I know I'm little
scumbag so what is this hole better help
thing fit in where where does I go I
mean you can't just treat your fans like
dollar signs what kind of person would
do that it's disgusting
and I don't understand why anyone would
do that my fans I treat with respect and
I would never sell them anything ever
check out the bars guys link in her
description please the campaign is only
nine days left
[Music]